êtes vous prêt à lancer votre carrière
de vidéastes créateur youtube earl donc
vous voulez gagner plusieurs milliers
d'euros
oui casse toi [ __ ] c'est fou ça les
gens rentrent comme ils veulent
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à ceux qui
créent des vidéos sur internet ou qui
veulent se lancer sur youtube ou
ailleurs puisque le site cdiscount fête
ses 21 ans je sais même pas qu'un site
pouvait avoir 21 ans c'est incroyable
et pour fêter ça il organise le festival
21 qui est un concours vidéo alors dans
ce concours forcément il faut poster une
vidéo et vous pouvez utiliser le
matériel que vous voulez une équipe du
tournage ou un smartphone importe peu on
s'en fout ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir des idées d'être créatif et moi
je suis très fier d'être dans le jury
donc je vais pouvoir voir ce que vous
allez proposer ou jugés et peut-être
vous faire gagner
il ya quand même quinze mille euros à la
clé pour les gagnants qui pourront
s'acheter ce qu'ils veulent sur le site
cdiscount voix c'est très pratique pour
s'acheter du matériel ou d'autres choses
pour se lancer
je trouve quelles sont les conditions
pour participer y en a très peu déjà
votre vidéo doit faire entre une minute
trente et cinq minutes et mia une seule
petite contrainte je sais pas si vous
savez il ya 21 ans cdiscount vendait des
cd des dvd
du coup la contrainte et la suivante il
faut que dans votre vidéo guînes scène
on voit un cd ou un dvd qui tombe au
clae de quelqu'un c'est tout vous
imaginez l'histoire ou le sketch que
vous voulez avec cette contrainte voilà
vous démerder laisser cours à votre
imagination et jeu quand même sympa je
vous propose d petite idée de ce que ça
peut donner à céder qui tombe au pied de
quelqu'un c'est qu'elle chérit chtouki
chéri j'ai rencontré quelqu'un et ça a
été un temps que tous les voir
ouais non enfin je restais juste pour
rester juste pour te dire que oui oui
voilà on a été le moins heureux yes une
seconde d'inattention et on ou des robes
les bijoux de la reine que tu as fait
porter à son cou ovale de ce soir ici la
brigade du bon goût on sait ce que vous
avez en votre possession
sortez nous de sport
je suis désolée c'était pour
l'adversaire devons donc je reviens chez
m je suis allergique mec de merde c'est
un bosseur
c'est un string
il tombe non il se fait un bleu
japonaise pour un premier jour de stage
tu connais la boîte ici on génère un
milliard de revenus d'ailleurs la
question évidemment donc ça c'est de la
comptabilité
tu me classe tout ça par ordre
alphabétique il ya des halles et marchés
[Musique]
c'est juste pour vous montrer l'étendue
des possibilités
faites ce que vous voulez faites autre
chose bien évidemment moi j'ai très hâte
de voir ce que vous allez faire vous
avez jusqu'au 24 octobre donc dépêchez
vous ne perdez pas de temps
rendez vous sur le site festival 21
cdiscount.com pour voir les modalités
mais aussi des conseils pour produire
des vidéos et moi je vous dis bonne
chance
[Musique]